Frogs and toads jump, swim, climb, even glide.
But four strange species of amphibians prefer to walk.
They don’t walk like dogs or other four-legged beasts.
Instead, they crawl low to the ground.
They stretch their front legs out
while crouching their back legs.
The walking frogs’ front legs are a bit
shorter than their hind legs,
but they compensate for this with their stooping gait.
In the typical frog,
the difference between front and back leg length
is more extreme.
The researchers still don’t know why
the frogs prefer walking to hopping,
but all four species live in similar grassland habitats
that lack branches or foliage to latch on to.
So it may be a better idea to slink away
than jump when predators are near.
Evolution hasn’t entirely ruined the essence of these
species’ frogness, though.
One researcher says that the frogs
can still jump and swim –
they just usually don’t.